so meanwhile the taliban proving that
they are back and back with vengeance
so here is some video last night you
could be forgiven if you saw this video
and you thought these were american
military members walking into an
american base they are not these are
members of the taliban who have american
gear they are outfitted in american
uniforms they're wearing american night
fission goggles and they are walking
into an american air base where there
are in fact american helicopters so uh
well done everyone
they are carrying american rifles
they're clad in american in american
uniforms
we're here right now
with the taliban as they enter into the
what was only minutes ago
uh it was an american controlled portion
of the military airport
now they've taken over
and there they are all wearing american
gear
so um they uh they didn't just uh defeat
the americans in their own view and
they're now wearing around their skin so
that is uh that is pretty amazing also
remember there was this talk about their
goat herders they can't fly helicopters
yeah um uh yesterday they were flying
around our helicopters here's some video
from kabul
so apparently they found somebody who
knows how to at least fly a helicopter
glad we gave them a helicopter so you
the law-abiding american citizen you
cannot have an ar-15 but the taliban
will just hand them our helicopters
and uh they're using it's a good effect
the helicopters allegedly there's video
that emerged from kabul yesterday of
them using our helicopters to excellent
effect uh namely to take their enemies
and tie them to the bottom of the
helicopters and then hang them scarface
style so this this video emerged
yesterday
[Music]
you can see there is a person who is
hanging from the bottom of the
helicopter
so things are going incredibly well in
taliban land already meanwhile remember
that time that joe biden said al qaeda
wasn't in afghanistan that we defeated
al-qaeda in afghanistan so our purpose
there was done oh yeah um one of the
al-qaeda leaders is back in fact this is
one of the co-founders of al qaeda along
with osama bin laden good friend to
osama bin laden he arrives back in
afghanistan to plot its cheers
a good thing that we said that we
wouldn't allow any country that harbors
al qaeda to its regime to survive
i've noticed not only at surviving but
uh they're back and they look exactly
the same as they did 20 years ago so i
hope you enjoyed that
meanwhile women are sitting outside the
kabul airport pleading and speaking
english saying uh where the hell are we
supposed to go now and they have a good
question here's some of that video
emerging yesterday
[Music]
president by then president of united
states please save us leave us our
families
save us our lives
we don't know what to do there please
help us please help our families we
don't know we are in danger it is many
days that we are outside the h career
and we didn't get access
what should we do please save us
we should be thankful and grateful guys
we should be praying in in gratitude to
the to the president of the united
states
and by the way um and jen saki was asked
okay so you've said that there's going
to be quote unquote over the horizon
capability here right you said that
we're going to be able to strike at
targets inside afghanistan terror
targets inside afghanistan
she was asked about this yesterday and
she had no good answer as to whether we
have any sort of actual over the horizon
capacity
is there any concern that we're limited
in our ability to respond in a timely
manner if we've got eight hours of
flight time and then they can only hang
out over the target for like four or
five hours before they've got to turn
around and go back is there a future
sort of ongoing
uh worry that we're going to be behind
the eight ball again
well first i would say the fact that we
have had two successful strikes
confirmed by centcom tells you that our
over the horizon capacity works and is
working
oh really because i noticed that that
over the horizon capacity was not over
the horizon that was that we had people
in afghanistan at the time now we don't
also one of those air strikes allegedly
killed an entire family so um
yeah
it turns out that the targets that
you're striking are only as good as the
people who are painting the targets
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment